i want to focus on what's going on over
in my what once was my hometown state of
new york we've got some info here from
the daily wire
new york democrat governor kathy hoschel
announced on wednesday that all 64 suny
college campuses are being directed to
update their policies to ensure that a
person's chosen gender identity and
pronouns are used
the policy will include chosen names to
appear on diplomas and campus profiles
along with the ability to select x as a
gender option by the fall 2023 semester
every person regardless of their gender
identity or the name they chose to go by
deserves to have identity documentation
that reflects who they are hochel said
in a statement the statement
specifically noted that the student's
chosen name and pronouns will appear in
campus portals class rosters and student
email addresses
among other changes stephen i want to
start with you on this one
i went to a suny school i went to suny
binghamton it was one of if not the best
suny school at the time i don't know
sort of where it ranks in that right now
uh but
this is pretty consistent with
everything coming out of new york
everything going across our
quote-unquote higher education uh right
now what do you make of this
well i mean i think it's pretty easy to
see that there is
obviously a certain kind of contemporary
prejudice and ideology behind
this kind of thing
but i do think it's pretty important
also to drill down to the level of
principle here
when there's a lot of coercion and
bullying into saying certain things i
think in this case we have to
acknowledge dave that this is merely
individuals stating their own
preferences now we may think that those
individuals may be influenced by a
very
anti-scientific ideology that is
destabilizing one of the most
fundamental categories of of human uh
beings the namely their their sex but we
should also remember that this is the
state university of new york it is uh
it is there for the people of new york
the governor is the elected head of the
state if the people don't like what she
is doing with their university they can
they can change it so i think that there
is a sense in which you could even
defend this as in the tradition of
american individual liberty however
misguided we may think what these people
are doing is uh no one's being forced
into anything you did not let me down
with a thoughtful answer as sort of
silly as we all may think it is yes
choice is there i kind of don't like it
coming from the state however
deborah i'm going to throw to you on
this one because they're also allowing
you to select x as a gender option now
it's one thing if you're saying okay i'm
going to call myself a different name or
i'm going to call myself another gender
x is not a gender is it am i missing
something deborah this is your
department
no i mean non-binary is not backed by
science whatsoever and so x would be i
guess for some people who want to be
special that's what they would have
designated on their driver's license or
a passport or birth certificate now
so i agree in with stephen in terms of
individual liberty and i think people
should be free to identify however they
want even if it is a scientific
anti-scientific concept and i go into
more of the science behind why there are
two sexes and only two genders in the
end of gender but you know when it's
being recognized by law this i find very
worrisome because why are ideas that are
anti-scientific being put into policy we
see this in medical policy scientific
organizations have capitulated to it and
i think it's just going to make it more
difficult for these ideas to be removed
from society when they are being given
legal sanctions
marissa i don't want to stab you right
to start but you live in california
which is the uh
let's say the west coast new york so
this is the type of stuff that if it is
not in the cali higher ed system will
obviously be there what do you make of
this
um you know i think it's interesting
when you talk about freedom because if
it was a private school would be a
different issue right you pay a certain
amount of money you don't like it take
your kids out put them in a public
school and you know hopefully live with
that but i think when public schools are
doing things like this the option of
freedom is no longer really there if
you're a parent who can't afford a
private school and you can't homeschool
your child how are you really free to
choose
not to mention i i understand your point
that one could then elect different
officials but if you think about the
spam of a life a child's life
the difference between kindergarten and
fourth grade those are four years of
having no option of making any sort of
change and this kind of idea that let's
you know vote with our feet or or pull
our kids out is not that simple for for
many parents it's the reality that you
do have to go to work and put your kids
in a school and can't wait four years
without them brainwashing your child and
essentially eroding the way they're
thinking stephen what do you make of
that point that we're all sort of agreed
on the on the civil liberty side and the
individual right side and the choice
side but that there's just this sort of
slow descent to hell with this thing
that will just keep bringing in ideas
that are wrong and then you know we can
we can defend per someone's individual
choice but that the system itself and as
marissa's saying okay you can elect
other people but people have four year
or six year terms and you know your kid
once they've sort of been infected by
this at five it's sort of uh out of the
barn by
nine ten years old
oh listen you you won't find a more
strident defender of uh freedom of the
freedom of the mind or uh opponent of
let's say propaganda and ideology then
than i am but i do want to say that this
is a very this is this is different
right i mean these are individual
stating preferences no one's being
forced into doing anything here and it
is not k to 12 public school this is the
the state university system of new york
no one is forced to go there and when
they do they're not forced to say that
they're any other gender than they want
to say so i do think we have to you know
it's important
if we're going to criticize our our
opponents for being reductive and
ideological then it's important that we
ourselves show nuance in the this
analysis and in this case uh however
idiotic i may think uh virtue signaling
uh in the worst kind of way this uh the
governor may be being in this instance
it is categorically different than what
we see at the elementary school level
and you're actually forcing children to
learn things that are
[Music]
dangerous and wrong